there's been in advance in a
sixty-year-old Matt's problem and a
maths problem which was related to the
four color theorem which is something
I've mentioned before
perhaps I should do a quick recap of
what the four color theorem was it's a
similar sort of thing really
before color theorem said imagine you
had a map right and I'm just going to
make up some sort of map here and the
idea was I want to color in this map so
that neighboring countries are not using
the same color so if I could have this
in it might be kind of this bit here the
idea being that any map can be done
using four colors or fewer or in other
words there aren't any maps that need
five colors so that's true that's a
facts right that was proven in the 1970s
but this problem that I'm going to talk
about today comes from the 1950s and
it's not something that's been solved
yet it's called the Hodge Widger Nelson
problem catchy name and I'm going to try
to quote you what the problem is how
many colors are needed to color the
plane so that no two points that unit
distance are the same color that's very
formal so let me just break that down
what it really means is imagine I'm
somewhere on this map here so there I am
and I'm going to go for walk I'm gonna
take a step and my step is going to be
one unit so these might not be countries
anymore because I'm changing the scale
of this so we're taking a walk and I
want to go one unit maybe that's one
unit whatever that means and then take
another step and I'll take one unit step
but every time I take a step I want to
step on to a different color I want the
color to change each time I step so I'm
gonna go for a walk I want to change the
color change the color we go change the
color again I could step back to here
change the color again change the color
again I could go over here but then for
example I couldn't walk this way because
if I take a one unit step over here I
wouldn't be changing the color so the
question is is there a way to color the
plane so imagine this as an infinite map
is there a way to color it so that I can
take a walk always changing the color
can I do it so I can take any
so any walk that I care to do I will
always be changing the color with each
step I take and that's the question no
matter what direction you no matter what
direction you pick no matter what walk
that I choose to do every step land on a
different color well four starts there
is a solution to this as seven colors
work we can do it with seven colors and
we can prove that really really quickly
you take the infinite plane we're going
to tile it with hexagons so I've got now
a little unit of hexagons I got seven
hexagons there and I've used seven
colors and now I'm just going to repeat
this over and over so I'm going to
repeat this so I'm creating a pattern of
colors with my hexagons now all I need
to do to solve this problem is imagine
the diameter of those hexagons was less
than one slightly less than one that
means that every step I take would be on
to a different hexagon so I could start
here and every step I take would have to
be on a different hexagon which is a
different color I just add one thing
though we wouldn't want to step from
this purple hexagon on to the next
purple hexagon which means I want this
distance to be greater than one which
means the diameter of your hexagons need
to be less than 1 and greater than 0.76
right fine that's all you need to take
the hexagons to be point 9 and the
problem is solved you can walk around
that hexagon infinite plane and change
the color with each step and even if I
wanted to step on one of the same color
couldn't do it even if you wanted to
even if you tried you can't because
those hex cons are chosen so that you
can't step onto the color try to annoy
cool what's the problem exactly what's
the problem so we definitely have a
solution and it can be done for seven so
the question is can it be done for six
colors or can we do it with five colors
for three to write how many colors
what's the fewest colors we can do this
with so we can eliminate some of the
answers really quickly you can't do it
with two I'll show you that so imagine
we try to do it with two so all I'm
going to draw out is the walk I'm just
going to draw a walk so I'm walking in a
triangle Annette Cole actual triangle
now let's try and color this wall so say
I start in the green region and then
take a step and I want it to change
color so now I've stepped onto a blue
region then I want to take another step
and I want to change color now I've only
got two colors available so I'm gonna
have to step onto a green region here
but that means if I want to step back to
where I started and there's no reason
why I can't do that I'm not changing the
color I'm starting from green to green
that's not allowed
visit an example of a walk that can't be
done with two colors it can be done with
three colors but it can't be done with
two well about three well again there's
an example it shows you can't do it with
three so same sort of idea here's a
specific example every step there in
that shape is one unit so you're walking
around that path great but can I do this
with three colors let's start with green
and then I move on to the next step well
it might be blue no one to step here
this has to be a different color so
let's have a different color that's have
red now if I want to step on to the next
one where it can't be red so that's make
it or you can't be green as well because
I don't want to step back to the green
so it has to be believed so that one's
pretty okay now what if I take another
step I think I've got a choice here I
don't I think I can choose my color I'm
gonna choose green here for the middle
now for this if I take one step up or it
can't be green it can't be blue so it's
red and if I step down to here it can't
be blue green or red so I need a fourth
color I can't do it with three it can be
done before and then that's where we got
to 16 years ago that's as far as we got
we showed that it can be done with seven
it can't be done with two it can't be
done with three so maybe it could be
done with four five six and seven we
know is definitely true and that's where
we were 60 years until recently so in
2018 an amateur mathematician found a
walk an example of a walk that can't be
done before which means he can only be
done with five which means four is not
the solution so we've eliminated four
colors from this problem
so I call him an amateur mathematician I
think that's a bit of a disservice this
is a person called all Breda Gray who
the biologist who's famous in his own
right in his own field
he works in anti-aging he's a very
interesting guy himself but he does
maths for fun and this was a problem he
was trying to do for fun and so he came
up with a walk that can't be done with
four colours and what he did is he took
this example it's got a name he's called
the most nurse bindle exchanged name and
he made copies of that which he fused
together so he fused together lots of
copies of this and he created this
monster this monster Network 20,000
points huge thing and then he got a
computer to show that four colours are
not enough it can't be coloured in
before and it can be cut in with five
fantastic we sit eliminates four for the
first time and sixty years he then
improved that he wanted to find a
smaller example smaller than this
monster and he got an example that's I
think 1581 points so that's much better
right so much smaller example but it's
the same thing it's an example that
can't be colored with four colours can
be done with five so then he published
this and map petitions got stuck in they
said well can we do better can we find a
smaller one the smallest we found so far
is this one here so this is a walk
found by Martin hooli who we have
mentioned before we talked about this
guy and he colored in the Pythagorean
triples we did a video about Pythagorean
triples and coloring in the red and blue
similar sort of problem and he found
this example it's a walk with 533 points
that needs five colors so we've got red
green blue and yellow
and then the fifth color is white which
is used only once right there in the
center
this episode has been brought to you by
brilliant the website that's full of
questions and quizzes and puzzles and
courses and all sorts of things to make
you smarter you're seeing some examples
on the screen right now they have all
sorts of new things every day but
they're not just dumping stuff on the
website all sorts of weird conundrums
for you to solve everything on brilliant
has been designed with a purpose in mind
and that's to really make the people
using it smarter to change the way you
think to make you a bit of problem
solver it's really about enriching the
people who use brilliant not just giving
them questions and then marks out of 10
there's loads of stuff on the brilliant
site you can look at for free so go
ahead and do that if you sign up for
their premium subscription which gives
you access to everything you can get 20%
off that by going to brilliant org slash
numberphile 20% off and they know you
came from here now if I've done my job
correctly the URL should be down below
me right now and down in the video
description